welcome back we are here with chelsea
clinton all right so i found a picture
chelsea and it just
it really it did everything in my heart
i i love this picture so much
look at how
lovely where is this okay so this is in
the governor's mansion um because my dad
was governor um i really wanted to be a
clown and i really wanted my mom to be a
clown and my mom just said okay and so
one of the reasons this is also so
special is this the last time we dressed
up together
yeah
well me love my mom this halloween
maybe it's time for twinning 2022. 20 20
22
yeah i'm in
i'm in all right so this is one of our
favorites this is one of your favorites
and can i thank i hope great about some
favorites in your life of course okay
are you ready let's do this
i'm like am i ready all right i'm ready
i know i feel like i also need to shake
it out a favorite present that your
parents got you
well probably the train set that i got
yeah i loved my train set um
yeah i think my train set that they gave
me for christmas when i was probably
about that age like five or six so you
were like they get me yes did they ever
get you a present where you're like they
don't get me
not really but i
i will say my
paternal grandmother my grandma gentry
who passed away when i was 13 and is one
of the great
i don't know if you can really regret
things you can't change and yet it feels
like this great regret for me that i
didn't know her as an adult
um
she
loved
everything bright
everything bright like she wore bright
colors she wore bright makeup everything
in her house was bright except for the
life-size cutout she had of elvis in
black and white in the corner this is my
point everything was bright and amazing
growing up everything was elvis
everything was right and then there was
elvis and and she would always and i
i have always had more
muted tones in my life and so every year
my grandma ginger would give me like the
brightest colored sweater or skirt or
like hair bows
um
and although
at the time i was like oh she doesn't
get me i now get what she was trying to
do
trying to bring brightness and she was
trying to bring her in to my life and i
wish that she would have lived long
enough so i could have said i understand
maybe you can say it wrong
okay favorite midnight snack
um
oh god it's so boring i really i really
liked
almonds and dark chocolate isn't that
boring i needed something more exciting
but it's the truth
yeah the truth is what i want okay i'll
try to be more exciting for the next one
and also truthful um okay your favorite
thing that your husband does around the
house
um
sings with our kids oh
it's it is really cute we we like i'm
sure many of you who have small children
um
we watch in kanto every week now and we
listen to the soundtrack every night
and it really my husband is such a good
sport and so like all of our kids are
singing
whatever
in their own registry of like we don't
talk about bruno and mark's like right
there with them um okay your favorite tv
show right now well i love the great
british bake off more than
maybe
any television show i've ever seen
people love it i really do love it and
my kids also like baking shows so we
watch baking impossible which was fun
where there's like a baker and an
engineer we just finished watching
school of chocolate okay favorite movie
right now
i mean i
i haven't seen any movie except for with
my children
i mean
i we
the other day i was like we have to take
a break from encanto i know
yeah we all love encanto and so then we
watch moana again and i was so happy to
see moana whereas like last year i was
like oh my gosh you need a break from
moana and then you're right have you
seen sing two we love singing and the
soundtrack is great the soundtrack is
great i highly recommend two though got
quickly displaced immediately by encanto
in our house okay throw on sing too yeah
um okay your favorite thing to do by
yourself nobody's watching
i no i like i do i run and i don't let
anyone run with me which is
maybe not the most generous place to be
but like my husband i'm like i love you
no
or even my friends who are big runners
like
i'm like that's great you can go right
and i'll go left
it is it is my
time it's my time
[Music]
you